but on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC Joy read and as you guys
know Joy Reed is a very well-paid racist
crazy person uh here she is completely
lying so this is a complete lie they
talk to you about misinformation and
disinformation they want us to be banned
silenced and visibility filtered and the
rest of it here's Joy Reid completely
falsely claiming that Republicans want
to prevent black history and the
existence of gays what does it say about
our society that for one of our two
major political parties the Salient
issue for them is stopping students from
learning black history and from even
discussing the existence of gay people
they have decided that is the most
important issue in the country more than
the economy more than anything else it's
stopping kids from learning those two
things right so that's Ibraham candy we
don't even need to listen to his
nonsensical answer but she knows she's
lying and what you must understand is
that MSNBC and the executive lives there
and anyone that puts her on television
they know she's lying too so you have to
know that they put her on television to
lie if anyone at MSNBC had a shred of
journalistic Integrity they would sit
her down and say actually Joy you
joyless Joy Joy it turns out they're not
trying to stop anyone from learning
black history in Florida it's actually
mandated by the state
gone repeating myself it's like you guys
know one AP class that had something to
do with gender queer studies that was
going to be incorporated into
African-American history that's what
this was about and that that he doesn't
want the existence of gay people to be
known you know it was funny yesterday so
I'm sitting again we have this little
six of us or so five of us and the
governor sitting there and we're all
getting to ask him questions and we're
talking and I start asking them a couple
questions and he full-on didn't see me
he erased my existence I was like gov
can you see me over here dude
it's so silly it's just so absolutely
ridiculous he actually asked me how the
kids are doing so that that's where
we're at with these people they are just
completely absolutely ridiculous
[Music]